Professor John Merriman:
Okay, I'm going to talk about
religion today,
yes, and what I'm going to
first--well, I'll talk just a
little bit about people who
weren't born into the Catholic
Church.
The vast majority of the
population of France at the
time, in the course,
until say 1960,
were born Catholic.
Now, whether they practiced
their religion is something
we'll come to in a minute.
Of the percentage of the
population of France who were
Protestants, which I'll talk a
little bit about in a minute,
is about five percent.
The number of Jews,
I think Chip Sowerwine tells
you in his book,
but I think it's about 300,000.
Now, first let me tell you
where Protestants and Jews were,
for the most part,
and why, just to give you a
sense of all this.
The Reformation,
in the sixteenth century when
it sort of--Calvinism expands
from Geneva,
where Jean Calvin had
considerable influence,
it spread really down the
Rhône River,
and it conquered large parts or
found adepts in large parts of
this part of France,
including Lyon.
Lyon was conquered back by the
Catholic Church,
as they would consider it the
Catholic Reformation;
or it used to be called the
Counter-Reformation,
but you don't call it that any
more.
But yet there were large
sections of the south of France
that remained Protestant,
and that still are.
Just in case it ever pops up in
a crossword puzzle,
the department with the largest
number of Protestants,
something like a third--it's
about what it was in the
nineteenth century--is the Gard,
g-a-r-d, that you would--that's
where Nîmes is the capital
of it;
and the second is the
Ardèche,
a-r-d-e-c-h-e,
which is where we hang out.
There also still and were
Protestants in the river
valleys, coming down to the
Rhône, particularly in the
Department of the
Drôme.
You don't have to remember all
this information.
Lots of Protestants in Lorraine
and in Alsace,
and, of course,
that had been amputated and
annexed to Germany,
and Protestants sort of here
and there.
Lots of Protestants,
when the Edict of Nantes,
that is, that gave toleration
to Protestants and was revoked
by Louis XIV in 1685,
lots of people tried to get out.
Lots of Huguenots,
as they were called,
went to Amsterdam,
to the Pays-Bas,
to the Netherlands,
and lots tried to go to Quebec
in Canada because they thought
it'd be easier to practice their
religion there.
But many of them couldn't
afford the passage and end up
living here in the Charente,
in the Charente-Maritime,
in this are here,
the Charente--that's a
beautiful city,
France's most beautiful city,
on the coast,
outside of Collioure,
La Rochelle,
the capital of the
Charente-Maritime.
And then you have Protestants,
of course, in Paris and in some
of the large cities.
What happens is after the
annexation of Alsace and much of
Lorraine by the German Empire,
many of the Protestants in
Alsace, and some in Lorraine,
moved.
Many moved to Belfort,
which became a territory,
not a department,
because of the heroic defense
of Belfort by a general during
the Franco-Prussian War.
So, there are your main centers
of Protestantism.
Now, what about Jews,
who get rights during the
French Revolution?
The first synagogue in France,
which is routinely targeted by
vicious graffiti and this sort
of thing,
is in the Vaucluse,
that is the
département of
Avignon, in a place called
Carpentras or Carpentràs,
you can say either word,
tras usually,
Carpentras usually,
on the other side of the
Rhône.
You have large concentrations
of Jews, Sephardic Jews,
in Bordeaux and in Paris and in
Alsace and Lorraine,
where there had been really
vigorous and vicious
anti-Semitic riots after the
Revolution of 1848.
And in Alsace,
interestingly enough,
the three religions,
that is, the Catholics,
the Protestants and the Jews,
tried to outdo each other in
charity.
They set up really remarkable
kind of voluntary associations
to help out poor people;
and it points to one sort of
interesting aspect of it.
So, that's just a sort of
overview.
But the vast majority of the
population were born into the
Catholic Church.
Now, because of the role of the
church in the
counter-revolution,
of the great French Revolution,
and because of the close
attachment of the Catholic
Church to the monarchy,
that is, support for the
ill-fated Comte de Chambord,
Henri V and all of that,
you have this tension between
the Catholic Church,
as a public institution,
and an increasingly powerful
state.
Now, one differentiation that
you should make is between
de-Christianization,
which I'm going to talk about,
and anti-clericalism.
Now, Voltaire,
the great philosophe,
he once said,
"crush the awful thing."
And he didn't mean religion
itself, what he meant was the
public institutional role of the
Catholic Church;
and he was--became the ultimate
sort of symbol of
anti-clericalism.
And anti-clericalism wasn't
necessarily anti-religiosity,
what it was was against the
public role,
the institutional role of the
Catholic Church in politics.
Thus, in French cities,
in the 1880s,
1890s, there are literally
battles over urban space where
laicized,
secularized and anti-clerical
municipalities want to refuse
the right of the Catholic Church
to stage processions of relics,
for example, on feast days.
In Limoges, which became La
Ville Rouge,
the Red City,
it had once been a very
religious town but they still
have this,
every seven years they still do
these processions where they
haul saints' relics through the
streets.
And so the municipality said,
no, you can't do that because
that is violating the neutrality
of public space.
And so thus you have this big
bagarre,
you've got this big brawl
between a church and laicizing,
secularizing municipalities
influenced by socialism;
and not necessarily against
religion but against the public
role of the Catholic Church.
And so that's kind of a
background for all of that.
Now, it used to be,
maybe 80 years ago--no,
less than that,
maybe 50 years ago--that one of
the interpretations of the
French Revolution,
the impact of the French
Revolution and the Empire,
the First Empire,
that is "N One,"
Napoleon the First who made
peace with the church,
was that it was the revolution
that destroyed that old-time
religion.
And in 1815 when Louis XVIII,
before this course cranks up,
comes back, he espouses the
view that church people had that
the revolution had been created
by people like Rousseau and
Voltaire,
and that they had been
responsible for moving France
away from that old-time
religion.
And as I said the other day,
after 1815 there is a revival
of intense religiosity,
in some regions.
You find the same thing in the
1870s, again the Republic of the
Moral Order.
And so that's what the church
wanted people to believe,
and many historians believe
that as well.
But along came a historian
called Michel Vovelle,
v-o-v-e-l-l-e,
who used to be the Professor of
the French Revolution at the
Sorbonne and he's kind of a
friend of mine,
or at least a good
acquaintance,
a very old dude now.
And Vovelle was interested to
see whether that old-time
religion was already crumbling
or in decline before the French
Revolution.
And so he started out asking
just how effective was the
Counter-Reformation or the
Catholic reformation,
if you will,
in bringing back,
reviving that baroque piety,
of a religion of faith,
of a religion in paintings of
swooning cupids,
of intense religious belief.
And what he discovered was that
in the parts of France that he
looked at, that that old-time
religion was already waning.
And thus we come to the
concept, which is important for
this course, and just in
general, of de-Christianization.
And de-Christianization means
two things.
First--again,
before this course--it meant
the campaign against the Church
as a public institution,
and really against organized
religion, undertaken by--during
the Terror, by Robespierre and
the others.
It meant melting down church
bells, it meant--meaning that
only priests who swore
allegiance to the French
Revolution,
to the nation,
could say mass,
and pretty soon putting them
under pressure not to say mass
at all.
But that's not what we're
talking about.
The residuals,
the remnants of that are still
important in the period we're
discussing.
But what Vovelle,
whose name I should write on
the board, in a book called
Baroque Piety and
de-Christianization,
which is looking at part of
Provence, started with that,
what he meant was that decline
in religious practice.
Now, it's very hard--imagine
you're in the story,
and that's what you are in this
course,
how are you going to prove
whether religion has that--has
still an important role in the
individual person,
or in family life,
or in public life,
if you're looking a long time
ago?
How are you going to know that
in a society in which in the
eighteenth century the majority
of people could not read and
write,
and in which the only things
about religion that you could
read were reports written by--or
sermons written by--published by
bishops and archbishops,
or reports sent by those
delegates of bishops and
archbishops going around France,
going around their dioceses to
see how many--what the state of
religion was?
How do you do that,
how do you know what--whether
people went to church or not?
How do you know that?
And so what he did was the
following, and this was--talk
about tough work,
that there are ways of doing
this.
Let me just give you a couple.
For example,
I don't know how--some of you
raised Catholic.
I was raised Catholic.
I was once thrown out of
religion class and paddled in a
Jesuit high school in Portland,
Oregon because the guy had
messed up Thomas Aquinas's
proofs of the existence of God
and I thought I was a smart-ass
and I could prove that God
couldn't exist by what he'd
done,
and so they threw me out of
religion class.
But, so I don't know if that
would be a statistic in this
kind of evolution,
but basically what--in the
Catholic Church babies have had
to be--I don't know if it's
still the case--but had to be
baptized within the first three
days of birth;
thus all these certificates
that have--remember the acte
de temoignage,
where people say,
"I see this baby,
the baby is alive," and they
baptize the baby so if the baby
dies--and remember babies died
all the time,
after childbirth.
If you made it to one,
year one, you had a good chance
of living to the ripe old age of
40--that if you didn't baptize
the baby and the baby died,
then the baby was going to go
to limbo or something and sort
of float around;
there were all these popular
beliefs about limbo.
And so what he did is he went
out and he looked at all these
baptisms, certificates of
baptism,
thousands of them,
to see how long it was
that--how long did people,
after the birth,
did they baptize their children.
And now people had already
started thinking about that.
The first religious
sociologists were priests,
at the end of the nineteenth
century, who said,
"people don't go to church
anymore, why not?"
And so they went out and they
began to--in fact one of the
people whose work I most admire
is an old,
very old, he must be 110 or
literally 90,
a priest in Limoges who used to
go out and look in the
cemeteries to see what people
had written on tombs,
and he looked at the names that
people named babies--more about
that in a minute.
So, what Vovelle found,
and what subsequent historians
of religion have found,
are that the curve goes
something like this:
three days to a month to two
months to six months.
And in the nineteenth century
increasingly,
in parts of France--that's
key--never.
And then are other things you
could do.
When people of means died they
left wills.
In the 1830s in Paris
seventy-five percent of the
population left nothing to
nobody because they had nothing
to leave anybody,
and they couldn't afford to
have anybody draw up a will,
they couldn't afford a lawyer
or a notary to draw up a will.
And so what Vovelle found was
that where people had in earlier
times, at the height of the
Counter-Reformation or the
Catholic Reformation,
in the seventeenth century,
they had left money to have
masses said for their souls,
or they had left money to
Catholic institutions caring for
lepers or caring for other sick
people,
or foundling homes.
And increasingly they stopped
doing that, in the areas that he
looked at, and they started
leaving money to lay
associations,
or to somebody else,
to their uncle or to their
children, and no longer 150
masses said on their anniversary
or their birthday,
for the repose of their mortal
soul.
And then you can look at
religious vocations.
There are parts of France that
have always had a lot of
priests, Finestère,
Brittany, for one example.
So, you could look,
and what he discovered was that
the number of people going into
the clergy,
men and women,
declined rapidly in the parts
of Provence that he looked at.
Now, that's a good sign.
What about names?
There's another one.
This is--talk about boring
work, but this is what this guy
in Limoges did.
When people start naming their
babies, when they stop naming
them after saints,
that tells you something.
For example,
in the Limousin,
this is an example,
but in the Limousin the saints
that were big time saints there,
one is Léonard,
like Leonard,
and another was Martial,
the name Martial.
And so this guy looked and
people stopped naming their
children Martial and Leonard,
Léonard.
And that tells you something
too.
Or a more obvious one would be
women's names.
You may, but you probably don't
know people named Mary
Magdalene.
And during the French
Revolution a lot of people took
old Roman names and started
naming their babies things like
Gracchus and names like that.
But you can look--you don't
know anybody named Gracchus I
bet--but you can--this was
another way that you could do
it.
And there's other ways too.
Remember, I said that one of
the published sources you can
actually read are these bishops'
sermons because they were
published every year,
and when these bishops'
sermons, and now I'm talking
more about the nineteenth
century,
when they start talking about
the dark secrets--what are the
dark secrets at a time of
plunging birthrate?
Birth control, birth control.
And that tells you something
very indirectly as well.
And what about even going to
mass?
In the Catholic Church you're
supposed to go to mass on Sunday
and you're certainly supposed to
go to mass, and confession,
on Easter, at Easter time.
And so that's one of the things
they had the priests count up.
They would count people who
were in the church.
And what you had is again an
astonishing decline of the
number of people going to
church.
Just an aside,
because I worked with a
sociologist and the first
thing--well I didn't have a job
one year,
the first year after I finished
my degree at Michigan,
Mighty Michigan,
maize and blue forever--I
taught sociology,
and so I was used to counting
things.
I worked with a great
sociologist called Charles
Tilly.
And so one day,
because I was writing a book
about our village,
and with my daughter then,
who was about 11,
we heard the bells ring,
there's--for church,
and there's only a Mass about
every six weeks,
more about that later,
and I said, "well,
let's go up and count the
number of people in church."
And there's a huge gap between
men and women in the church
attendance.
It was true in the nineteenth
century and it's true now.
So we go to the back of this
church and we start counting the
number of people,
and there were eighteen people.
And my daughter,
then eleven,
all of a sudden said,
"mais papa,
même les femmes sont
chauves," even the women are
bald.
And, of course,
then everybody in the church
turned around and looked at us
standing in the back,
and she had a cruel point
there;
she didn't mean to be cruel but
it was that most of the people
who went to church were very old
ladies.
But the priests,
even now, and this particular
village does not have a regular
priest and it has not had for
decades,
they count the number of people
who are there on Easter.
And what you had is this
precipitous decline in the
number of people going to
church.
So that is de-Christianization.
Let me give you another
example, from World War I,
war memorials.
Many of you have had my
friend--some of you may have had
my friend Jay Winters' course
and he works--he's done a lot of
work on war memorials.
And if you go to parts of
France that were very
de-Christianized,
more about this later,
if you go to the Creuze or up
here to the Nièvre here
or the Allier,
those are sort of classic
examples of very
de-Christianized parts of
France,
even the war memorials were in
some places where you practiced
religion, the war--the
number--the monument to the dead
will be near the church.
In some of those places the
monument to the dead is not only
not near the church that no one
goes to,
but will have a broken cross,
asking that same question that
Voltaire once asked about the
Lisbon earthquake:
"if there is a God,
how could he or she have
allowed this to happen?"
And even those monuments are
symbols of a decline in what had
been assumed by the church,
and indeed assumed by the
state, of that old-time
religion.
But now, is this true
everywhere?
Well no, not at all,
and that's one of the points,
and that's one of the reasons
that I insist--and if you don't
have one,
please come up and get one
later--those handy little maps
with the regions and the
départements;
because there are huge
differences, and these
differences were already
apparent in the eighteenth
century.
The French Revolution was,
above all, this civil war,
a war about religion.
And if you take a map from 1789
or 1790, '90,
when the priests had to either
swear to the nation,
to the French Revolution,
or refuse to swear to the
Revolution and to the nation,
and you take that map and you
put it along a map of the
elections of May 1849,
and you put that on top of a
map of the election of
François Mitterrand as
President of France of 1981,
they're almost the same,
with very few changes.
And one of the predictors--here
I sound like a sociologist,
which I am not--but one of the
predictors of all of that is
de-Christianization,
because the regions of
political conservatism are the
regions in which that old-time
religion was--which those
regions were less
de-Christianized than other
places.
So, where were the
de-Christianized regions,
where were the areas of still
intense religious practice,
just for the hell of it?
Auvergne, again Auvergne,
that's a region you should at
least know something about.
If you like gastronomy you'll
think of aligot,
fabulous garlic with potatoes,
or you'll think of stuffed
cabbage, you'll think of all
sorts of stuff.
But that's not what we're
talking about.
In Auvergne you still have
intense religiosity.
We have friends who once owned
a café
across from the National
Archives,
where I spend quite a lot of
time, in both institutions,
and they--the wife was from the
Vernon,
which is way down here,
Millau and all that,
and the husband is from Cantal,
which is up here,
Aurillac, there.
And they had thirteen and
twelve brothers and sisters,
respectively,
born in abject misery in the
1930s, just misery.
Classic, some of the babies
died, but that's a lot of
children.
Now, if you compare that,
if you go about--if you want to
drive about not even a day,
you get down here near Agen,
the Prune Capital of France,
and one of the rugby capitals
of France,
it was said,
and was true,
that if, and I mentioned this
the first day I think,
that if you had more--if you
had a second child in some
villages you received a
condolence card,
a condolence card.
Now, how different that is,
and those places aren't very
far away.
Well, the Lot-et-Garonne,
down here, is extremely
de-Christianized,
whereas Auvergne,
one of the things the Catholic
Church said was no dark secrets
baby, and have lots of children,
and send the younger ones into
the clergy, as sisters and nuns
and that sort of stuff.
Other areas of religious
practice: in Alsace Catholics,
Protestants and Jews all
practiced their religion,
very faithfully.
In the north of France,
particularly in Flemish parts
of the nord,
that old-time religion was
still practiced.
In much of Normandy,
the same thing,
though not in big cities,
less in Rouen for example;
and in Brittany,
above all, religion was
practiced, as it always had
been.
And there were huge numbers of
people going on what in they
call in Brittany the pardons,
which are religious ceremonies,
full of festivity as well.
Now what are the big
de-Christianized areas?
Almost any large city.
Even in the case of Brittany,
Brest, because it had so many
sailors who weren't from
Brittany there;
though a lot of Bretons were
sailors also.
For example,
in L'Havre there are lots of
Bretons who live in L'Havre;
but anyway that makes things
more complicated than they are.
Most big cities,
some exceptions--Lyon is still
fairly practicing Catholic;
Paris, totally lost to the
church.
One of the things,
if you go to the suburbs of
Paris, even the inner suburbs
that were annexed in 1860,
you'll see all of these
extremely modest and sometimes
just impossibly ugly churches
that were built in the 1870s to
try to re-conquer the working
class population that had been
lost in the working class
suburbs to the Catholic Church.
Sacré
Coeur, which I've already
denounced because of its
architecture,
standing on Montmartre,
the butte of Montmartre,
was there as a sign of penance
because of the Franco-Prussian
war.
But the cities were basically
lost to the Catholic Church,
with some exceptions.
But so were huge regions.
The Île-de-France,
the area around Paris,
here, the Île-de-France,
as it's called,
because you can imagine it kind
of vaguely as an island because
of all these rivers--extremely
de-Christianized.
The Limousin,
around Limoges,
totally de-Christianized.
The southwest,
absolutely, I forgot to mention
that where Bernadette of Lourdes
saw the Virgin Mary,
that that part of the Pyrenees
was still very Christianized.
Provence, much of Provence,
very de-Christianized as well.
And, as I said before,
the Bourbonnais--you don't have
to know these regions,
just know something about the
big ones.
So, there are big regional
disparities in this.
And this is background to the
separation of church and state
in 1905.
And two of the various laws
that you can read in Sowerwine's
book, the anti-clerical
legislation that really starts
in 1878,
1879, that will lead to
expulsion of some of the
religious orders and eventually
the de-coupling of church and
state in 1905.
Now, this, to be sure,
is a rather pessimistic,
from the point of view of the
church,
assessment, and perhaps overly
so, because there has been
recent work that has described
in many parts of France,
and in parts of Catholic
Germany also,
a revival of intense
religiosity that has a lot to do
with miracles.
Now, in the Catholic Church,
in bad times sometimes miracles
come along to kind of rescue the
church,
and the case of Bernadette of
Lourdes, before this course,
in 1856, was one of them.
Lourdes becomes one of the
first tourist sites in France,
after Paris,
because these--it's always
young girls,
by the way, always,
who see the Virgin Mary;
never young boys it's always
young girls, that's interesting.
The case of Marpingen in the
Saar in what,
1876, appear in Germany too.
It comes along at a good time
for the Catholic Church--or
Fatima, in Portugal,
in 1917.
It's always young,
illiterate shepherd girls who
see the Virgin Mary.
And then what happens is they
interview them,
they bring translators to
as in the case of
Bernadette--"what did you see?"
And they stick to their stories
and pretty soon,
the bishops are a little
skeptical,
and then they seize upon the
moment and this becomes God is
telling us something,
that we have sinned and the
Virgin Mary is looking after us.
So, it revives--it happened
also in the 1830s near Grenoble,
or was it was the '40s,
a place called La Salette--it
is a sort of classic.
And then, as I said the other
day, talking about the
railroads, the first and,
for many people,
only railroad trip they ever
took, people that in the 1870s
and the 1880s who didn't have a
lot of money,
is to where?
To Lourdes, to get--if they're
sick to try to be healed or to
buy holy water.
I just saw something the other
day, that they had a big
confrontation in an airport
because they refused to let them
carry holy water on the plane
because it was bigger than a
mini tube of toothpaste;
you know how they take away,
you can only have little
bottles instead of big bottles,
and it even happened on a papal
airplane or something like that.
So, we live in a very different
world now.
They didn't have to worry about
that stuff at the time of these
miracles.
But pilgrimages to Lourdes from
every diocese in France is still
something that you see all the
time.
But regional,
these regional outlines remain
very, very true,
indeed.
So, in 1905 what happens is the
church and the state get
separated, that the clergy are
going to be pretty much left on
their own now,
that the state has control over
religious buildings,
and this is bad news for
priests and for nuns.
Now when I--I admitted one
thing when I was talking about
the religious revival,
and this is something that goes
very--goes back to the
early--well not the early days
but it goes back at least to the
sixteenth century,
and probably earlier if I
knew--yes, earlier,
earlier than that,
it goes back to the medieval
period.
Now, the Roman Catholics' view
of women had left them pretty
much in a state of
subordination,
and that's always pretty much
been the case.
I went to a school that was a
Jesuit school,
as I said, that only--it was
mostly a sports factory and it
only had--and that's kind of
what I did--and it didn't have
women;
that was--they were just out
there somewhere.
And we used to like to go to
a--if you can imagine me as a
failed altar boy,
you're looking at one,
but we used to like to go out
to the girls school and help the
priests with the mass and all
that,
just to have a look at these
women who we had basically never
seen before.
But one of the things that
happens, happened in the
Catholic Church very early,
is that every time there's a
new kind of spurt of religious
adherence and belief,
is that convents,
female convents,
the religious orders,
are one of the places,
one of the only places that
women, smart,
upwardly mobile women,
can rise and have careers
worthy of their intelligence and
organizational skills,
if you think about it.
And so it's easy looking back
from our secular age and kind of
dissing all these people,
mumbling up in the mountains
someplace, or not speaking at
all, in some cases,
and just simply praying all the
time.
But what is often forgotten is
for women who couldn't possibly
do more than simply bear
children and do the best they
could in those circumstances
because the strictures of
society didn't give them
opportunity.
These convents actually have an
important role in their lives,
that is often simply forgotten.
And the role of women teachers,
even though many of them were
barely educated,
in very many parts of France
that were still practicing,
like our part of France,
it was extremely important.
And they had what they
called--they don't call them
obviously grandfather rules--but
they had essentially grandmother
rules,
a phrase they didn't use,
that meant that these teachers
who were female teachers who
were nuns,
who were allowed to teach in
the public schools until they
died, and they were given that
dignity to be able to stay and
teach there.
And their teaching was valued
for what they did.
And so again what one has
to--has to keep all these things
in perspective.
And for example there was a
woman, a friend of mine who did
a book, a long time ago,
which feminists just mauled,
they couldn't stand it,
but it's a very important book;
because what she looked at,
the sort of upper class ladies
in the north,
such as those people you're
going to read about in
Germinal--so that's a
nice transition,
a vaguely nice transition--and
that one of the things that they
were able to do because of their
intense religiosity was organize
their own households in ways
that they wanted to,
with crucifixes and statues of
the Virgin Mary and all this
kind of stuff,
and that they carved out their
own separate sphere and
participated in their charitable
activities.
So, from the point of view of
the Catholic Church,
or for religiosity in general,
religious practice,
all the news is not bad,
but indeed most of it was.
And having said what I've said,
it's easy for you to,
if I ask you this,
to say in what regions were
people mad as hell about the
separation of church and state,
and about the inventories that
followed in 1906,
you would already know the
answer.
Now, what were the inventories?
The inventories were where they
sent some state inspector around
who's going to say,
"we're going to look at all the
paintings in this church and to
assess their value."
Now, even in very modest
villages, of almost no means,
they all had some sort of
paintings,
often just terrible art,
but you never know,
maybe you're going to stagger
into a Rubens or something like
that,
purely by accident,
on the border of Flanders,
of Belgium--you don't know
that.
And so they sent around these
inspectors.
And in many cases the faithful
lock themselves in the church,
they barricade the church,
and then they have to bring
soldiers in, and this was kind
of bad, the soldiers are camping
in fields near the church,
then they have to conscript
locksmiths, from the towns,
to come and force open the
locks.
And in many cases that doesn't
work, so they have to bring
people with huge axes.
So, again, from the point of
view of the church,
this is the martyrdom of Saint
Sebastian again,
this is the martyrdom of
ordinary people at the hands of
a cruel, secularizing,
centralized state,
working against the interests
of ordinary religious people.
Now, to be sure,
the Catholic Church had not
done itself any great favors
with the Papal Syllabus of
Errors in 1864 that said that
modernity,
liberalism, democracy,
helping workers,
anything, was bad,
and it made the church look
pretty ridiculous.
And also, there was a huge
controversy then over a papal
pronouncement in 1871 that said
that when the Pope puts on a
certain hat that he is
infallible,
infallible.
Now, we don't pay attention to
this now, nobody pays attention
to this now, I guess,
I had completely forgotten
about it, but at that time,
what if the Pope puts on a
certain hat and says,
"you'll be excommunicated and
burn in hell forever if you vote
for a Liberal or a Socialist"?
Voilà.
So, what's that going to do?
So the church didn't do itself
any favors in being provocative.
But by 1905 and 1906,
the Catholic Church in the wake
of the Dreyfus Affair,
more about that another time,
where the Catholic Church went
after Dreyfus;
it was better that he be
guilty, even if he wasn't
guilty, because he was a Jew.
By then you have this
ralliement,
or rallying of the church to
the Republic as an institution,
and so things should have been
better, when they go around and
knock on the door and try to get
into these churches.
But they weren't,
and people barricaded
themselves into these churches.
And so I got interested in
this, and, for example,
in our particular village,
one of the things that people
told--were passed down
generation after generation,
is that the troops had been
bivouaced in the field behind
the new church,
which had been started in 1896
to replace the old Romanesque
church,
which is disaffected or
désaff
ecté,
whatever you call it,
taken out of commission,
right across from where we
live, actually,
and that the troops had come
with axes and had broken down
the doors of the church,
and that people had gone home
with pieces of the door,
cherishing them as you would a
piece of the true cross,
on which Christ was crucified.
And this was handed down from
generation to generation,
and people talked about it as
if they had been there--even
folks who hadn't been to church
in ages and ages.
Now, I got interested in this,
because I was writing a book
about this place,
and so I went to all the
archives, of course,
and I went to all the
newspapers,
the Catholic newspaper and to a
very anti-clerical socialist
newspaper, and I read the
accounts of all the incidents in
which that happened,
in all these other villages,
in this part of France in which
tensions between Protestants and
Catholics had always been very
high because of the wars of
religion in the sixteenth
century,
the seventeenth century,
and in the eighteenth century.
And what I discovered was that
the event never happened,
it never happened,
that there were no troops ever
bivouaced outside of the church
in this particular village
called Balazuc,
and that there was never a time
that the door was bashed down by
soldiers with axes,
to look at the modest paintings
on the walls of this poor church
whose parishioners had almost
nothing.
The event never happened,
it did not happen.
But nonetheless in their
imaginaire,
or in their--the constitution
of their memory it had a place,
which is that they were
defending their church against
these forces from the outside,
rather like the case of our
school, that they couldn't
control.
So it had a place there,
even though it never happened.
It could've happened but it
just didn't, it never happened.
So what's the point of all
that--is that separation of
church and state was
extraordinarily wrenching in
areas that were not
de-Christianized,
although there were instances
in some of the other ones as
well, and that people simply got
by as best they could in the
church continuing to draw people
on Sundays and to religious
holidays,
and that--which was the case in
our village.
And our village had a priest,
the last one who was denigrated
as a red-haired ladies' man by
some of his enemies,
he left I think--well we got
there 20 years ago,
so about four years before we
were there.
And as I said the other day in
the context of the schools,
the Catholic Church now is just
a voluntary association in our
particular part of France,
like any other one.
There are no more people from
our village who go to that
church than will turn up at X,
to play bingo for the school,
far fewer, from that point of
view.
But it doesn't mean that the
church doesn't have some place
in the collective memory of the
place,
even a lot of it is imaginary
or some of it's imaginary.
Once there was a huge
windstorm, as there frequently
is, and we always have the
rivers--in fact it was the
22^(nd) of September 15 years
ago the river rose so
dramatically it killed about 200
people,
not in our part,
not our particular river,
but across the Rhône,
when a big storm came and the
statue,
this rather ugly statue of the
Virgin Mary crashed to the
ground and broke into one
hundred pieces,
or 1,000 pieces.
In the café
that's open all year they put
up a bowl and people who are
very anti-Clerical always put
money into the bowl to rebuild
this statue,
because people care that this
voluntary association remain;
and that it's still--in the
Catholic Church you call them
four-wheeled Catholics,
people still will go there for
baptism, for burial--not in this
order--and for marriage.
And I have assisted at,
with my family,
combined baptism/marriage
ceremonies where a couple will
marry years and years after
having children,
which is pretty usual actually
in our part of France,
among many of our fiends,
and they're still very much
couples, they just never got
married.
In France, in Paris in the
nineteenth century a quarter of
all couples who lived together
weren't actually married.
It wasn't that they were just
defying organized religion,
it was that they didn't have
money to pay to have a marriage.
And if you ever read
L'Assommoir,
when they do get married--Zola,
one of his other great novels,
when they go down to the Louvre
it's one of the great scenes in
French literature,
so far as I know.
So, but the trouble with the
Catholic Church in France is of
course there's no priests
anymore, and just end with it
there;
that something like I read in
Libé or one of the
newspapers that well over half
of all the priests in France now
are--oh,
sixty-five percent of them are
over sixty years old,
and something like forty-five
percent are over seventy,
and there are almost no
religious vocations at all,
even from religious areas now.
So, because churches do provide
charity still and help organize
lives for very elderly people,
this is very sad.
And even Voltaire,
who once said that if God
didn't exist he or she should be
invented so that he wouldn't be
cheated by his wife or his
tailor,
even Voltaire would have agreed
that the church,
churches still in France fill
some useful function.
But these regional contrasts
are still extraordinarily
important in
de-Christianization,
helped define the evolving
politics of La Belle
France.Apologies again for
this colossal mess about the
room;
we will take care of this as
soon as possible,
like in the next ten minutes.
So have a great weekend,
and have fun in section.
See ya.